[موسيقى]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير نحييكم الى
بانوراما نناقش فيها اليوم ملف على عده
اجزاء ونبدا بالعناوين
اتفاق سعودي راني لعوده العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه بعد سبعه سنوات من القطيعه
وعامين من المفاوضات فما هي تحديات التي
تواجهه وما الفرص متوقعه من وراءه
لماذا كانت القطيعه ولماذا نشهد عوده
للعلاقات بين طهران والرياض الان
[موسيقى]
وهل سيتكرر سيناريو 2001 عندما فشلت اتفاق
المشابه ام ستستفيد كل الاطراف من دروس
الماضي
اهلا بكم بعد عامين من المفاوضات وسبعه
اعوام من القطيعه في العاشر من مارس اعلنت
السعوديه وايران عن استئناف العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه بينهما واعاده فتح سفارتي
البلدين
وممثلياتهما خلال شهرين برعايه الصينيه
وصدر بيان الثلاثي مشترك من البلدين ودوله
الوساطه اي الصين اتفق فيه الجانبان على
احترام سياده الدول وعدم التدخل في شؤونها
الداخليه وتفعيل اتفاقيه التعاون الامني
الموقعه بين السعوديه وايران عام 2001
واضاف البيان المشترك كان الرياض وظهران
تؤكدان على احترام سياده الدول وعدم
التدخل في شؤونها الداخليه كما اتفق
البلدان على ان يعقد وزير الخارجيه في
البلدين اجتماعا لتفعيل ذلك ولترتيب تبادل
السفراء الى جانب تفعيل جميع الاتفاقيات
المشتركه بين الدولتين ومنها اتفاقيه
التعاون الامني اتفاقيه التعاون في مجال
الاقتصاد والتجاره والاستثمار والتقنيه
والعلوم والثقافه والرياضه والشباب وشدد
البيان على ان قرار استئناف العلاقات بين
البلدين جاء نتيجه استجابه لمبادره من
الرئيس الصيني ورغبه قيادتي البلدين في حل
الخلافات من خلال الحوار والدبلوماسيه
السعوديه وايران اتفاق استئناف العلاقات
اهم بنود الاتفاق احترام سياده الدول وعدم
التدخل في شؤونها الداخليه
الموافقه على استئناف العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه اعاده فتح سفارتي البلدين
وممثلياتهما خلال مده اقصاها شهران تفعيل
اتفاقيه التعاون الامني الموقعه في 2001
تفعيل الاتفاقيه العامه للتعاون في مجالات
الاقتصاد والتجاره والاستثمار والتقنيه
والعلوم والثقافه والرياضه والشباب
الموقعه عام 1998
التقارب ما الذي يختلف هذا المسار عن غيره
مساء الخير
الكرام طبعا يختلف في في عده نقاط يختلف
اولا انه تحول جذري في مفهوم التعاطي في
المنطقه
يختلف في انه اول يعني اهم دولتين في
المنطقه تتفقان على اطار عام كان
الاشكاليه ناسيه في المفاوضات السابقه
اعتقد في الجانب الاساسي انه هناك كانت
متطلبات سعوديه وكان هناك يعني تجاوب
ايراني نقول او او ترحيب راني بقيام بهذه
المتطلبات او مستلزمات لكن خط الثقه كان
معدوم لم يكن هناك ضمانات لم يكن هناك
امكانيه للوصول الى نتيجه كان الخيار
الوحيد ان تبقى الامور مطروحه الى ان تقوم
ايران بالاجراءات ثم بعد ذلك تبدا الخطوات
في مساله استئناف العلاقات او التعاون
المشتركه وتطوير الاجراءات بين البلدين
حينما دخلت الصين بشكل اساسي رحبت المملكه
رحبت المملكه لعده اسباب اولا لنجد ان
الموافقه المملكه على اعاده العلاقات او
السناف العلاقات الاتفاق السرعه انا اعتقد
انه خدمه من المملكه لايران لو ان المملكه
كانت تتربى سوءا بايران كان اضطرت او طلبت
او ما طلبت او اجلت عمليه الاتفاق لفترات
اطول لان المشهد الايراني في الداخل
والخارج مزعج جدا ومحبط الايرانيين
ويوحي بتصاعد سيء قد يؤدي الى تكرار مشهد
عام 79
فهذه هذه الخطوه مجرد موافقه المملكه على
اجراء هذه المحادثات بهذه السرعه هذه نقله
نوعيه وهذا اشاره لحسن الجوار فعلا وليس
يعني اعتباطا النقطه الاخرى نجد ايضا
العمليه التفاوض تمت في سريه كامله لم احد
يسمع عن وجود وفدين وهذا اننا كانت تدور
في دوائر ضيقه جدا وعلى مستويات عاليه جدا
هناك تحقق الان المساله انه بالتالي
الضامن الفرق في المعادله انه ضامن يعني
الضامن الاساسي الذي يعطي هذه المصداقيه
هذا التقدير من المملكه للرئيس الصيني ولد
بدرته وبالتالي كان شرطا ان يكون موقع
الصين موقعه والطاوله كانت مثلثه هذه ليست
مفاوضات ثنائيه اكد عليها كانت مثلثه هناك
ثلاثه اطراف وحضرتك ترى عامل صحيح وحضرتك
ترى بانه حضور الصين هو الملفت في هذا
المسار وصفتها بالضامن يعني هي وسيط في
رتبه ضامن هي حاضره
ومتعهده بمتابعه هذا المسار معالي الوزير
هل تراك ضيفي بان
وساطه الصين هي التي يمكن ان تمثل الفرق
او ان الحاله عموما يعني هناك جو عام
تعيشه المنطقه والعالم في الواقع هناك
متغيرات تفرض نفسها هي التي فرضت مثلها
كذا مسار وفرضت مثل هكذا نقطه التقاء على
الاقل سنتحدث فيما بعد عند تداعياتها ولكن
نقطه التقاء في هذه المرحله يمكن البناء
عليها
النظام الدولي
تفضل نعم
النظام الدولي باكمله يمر بعاصفه مكتمله
وهناك تحولات جذريه عالميا واقليميا في
الشرق الاوسط هذه الخطوه خطوه جيده للغايه
خطوه اولى انما هي خطوه جيده للغايه تعكس
تقييم سليم للاطراف الاقليميه باهميه
التحاور
ارتباطا باحداث اليمن هذه خطوه ايجابيه
انما هي خطوه اولى نحو المزيد نرى او نامل
ان يترجم الى افعال وهذا ما سيقوم وجيري
الخارجيه بتقييم وتفعيله في المستقبل
تحدثت عن نقطه ملفته تحدثت عن اهميه
الطرفان يعني حتى وان كانت هناك وساطه
صينيه داعمه ولكن يجب ان يكون هناك طرفان
يؤسسان لثقه معينه ويدفعان بهذا المسار
هذه النقطه سانقلها لك دكتور هاشميان هل
هناك شيء تغير وكانه هناك اعلاء لمصلحه
المنطقه للمصلحه العامه على المصالح
الذاتيه هل هناك شيء تغير في حسابات
الطرفين اتحدث السعوديه وايران
نعم تحياتي لكم والى ضيوف الكرام ومشاهدين
البرنامج انا اعتقد هناك تغيير اساسي
موجود في داخل ايران وكما راينا الفريق
المفاوض الذي وصل الى هذه
الاتفاقيه هو ليس من الوزاره الخارجيه او
امير عبدالله يانو جماعته وانما هناك وفد
مباشره من علي خامني يتراسه علي الشمخاني
امين عام المجلس الاعلى للامن القومي هذا
يعني اعتراف واضح من علي خامني بان حكومه
ابراهيم رئيسي ووزاره خارجيته ليس موفقه
في هذا الاتجاه على الرغم من ان ابراهيم
رئيسي جاء بشعارات بتحسن العلاقات مع
الدول الجوار وخاصه المملكه العربيه
السعوديه ولكن هناك فريق اخر وهو فريق
القريب الى حكومه حسن روحاني ومن معروف
بالمجموعه
دخلت في هذا الموضوع
ووصلت الى نتيجه واعتقد ان في الاوضاع
الحاليه خاصه هناك ثلاث متغيرات موجوده
تستطيع ان نقول ان تضغط على النظام
الايراني اولا الوسيط الصيني المهم والقوي
في الساحه الدوليه والاقليميه هو الان
الذي يعطي ضماناته الان الذي يطلب من
النظام الايراني بان يعيد النظر في
علاقاته مع المملكه العربيه السعوديه خاصه
فيما يتعلق بتدخلات النظام الايراني في
المنطقه هناك محور ثاني ونقطه ثانيه تتعلق
بالاوضاع الاقتصاديه المنهاره في داخل
ايران مثلا اليوم رئيس اللجنه المتعلقه
بالميزانيه شمس الدين الحسيني في البر قال
ان العام القادم سيكون اسوا من الوضع
الحالي وهذه افاق جدا متفجره في الاوضاع
الاقتصاديه ايضا
الثوره والاحتجاجات المستمره التي الان
تهدد كيان هذا النظام كل هذه المجموعات
انا اعتقد ضغطت على النظام بشكل كبير ان
ياتي
بكين ويقوم بهذه الاتفاقيه ويريد اعاده
العلاقات مع المملكه العربيه السعوديه
ولكن هذا ليس بمعنى ان النظام الايراني
يتخلى عن ميليشياته ودعمه
الميليشيات انا اعتقد الموضوع الاساسي
المتعلق بالمنشيات والتغيير الاساسي اذا
حصل ومتعلق بالمنشاد هو تغيير
الامور من فيلق القدس من المجموعه
المتعلقه بفيلك القدس الى المجموعات
المتعلقه بالوزاره الخارجيه هو المجموعات
الدبلوماسيه حتى الان موضوع الميليشيات
ودعمه من قبل فيلق القدس لم يحصل ولم تسحب
الورقه من القدس في هذه الموضوعات
الحساسيه هو لما نتكلم عن الميليشيات
العراقيه وكان الموضوع سيناقش في مراحل
المتقدمه
بجزئيات منفصله عن بعضها يعني كل بلد كل
دوله كل ملف سيكون منفصل
الحديث عن ميليشيات بشكل عام لا نعلم مدى
امكانيه وضع هكذا ملف ثقيل على الطاوله
ولكن استاذ جاسر
حقيقه بعد كل ما تحدثتم به عن تفاصيل تدعم
هذا المسار هل تعتقد بانه هناك فرص حقيقيه
لانجاح في هذه المرحله
بالطبع احنا يعني التفاؤل يعني كما ذكر
حتى الامير فيصل فرحان لابد ان نتفاءل هذه
حركه ايجابيه هذه خطوه للامام الخطوه
دائما افضل من السكون وافضل من يعني عدم
الحركه فالتالي لو بقيت الامور معلقه لم
يحدث لكن هل تنجح العمل انها تنجح واذا لم
تنجح سنعود الى النقطه لنفسها يعني في
الجانب بالتالي الخيار هناك نافذه شرعت
هناك باب فتح بايران تحديدا في المنطقه
وعليها ان تدرف منهن لتكون شريكا عليها ان
تحول او تغير صبغتها عليها ان تخلع
عباءتها الايدولوجيه بالكامل اذا كانت
نعتقد انه الان في تفاؤل لانه في ايران
ازمه داخليه حتى بعيدا عن الضغوط الخارجيه
المتواليه هناك ازمه داخليه خانقه جدا قد
فعلا تعيد مشهد 79 فبالتالي
لعل وعسى نقول ان هناك اعاده تفكير في
المنظومه في الايراني في داخل انها تعيد
ترتيب اولوياتها بما يحقق ان تكون شريكه
في المنطقه وليس عبان يعني علاقتنا ايران
علاقه سيئه لا نذكر صفحه ايجابيه اتكلم عن
النظام الايراني لا اتكلم عن الشعب
الايراني ولا اتكلم عن الجيره تكلم عن
ممارسات النظام الايراني سيئه لا يوجد
صفحه بيننا وبينهم صراحه الخاصه صفحه
ايجابيه لا يوجد صفحه واحده من التهديدات
من ارسال الخلايا من المخربين في المملكه
هذا بشكل مباشر التدخلات في المنطقه
استخدام الاسلحه جميع العمليات الارهابيه
الارهابيين كلها ولذلك هناك في نقطتين
ستحدد ان اعتقد خلال فتره وجيزه المساله
التعاون الامني التعاون الامني اعتقد انه
بدا من امس يفترض يعني اذا كانت لان هناك
النقاط يجب ان تحسم هذه الملفات المتصله
بالعمليات التخريبيه بشكل اساسي والعناصر
المخربه التي ترسل ايران والعمل على
اساسها بحيث تكون هذه وحده من المسارات
التي المؤدي الى النقطه الايجابيه في
الشهرين وايضا التحرك سريع بشكل فاعل
وايجابي في الملف اليمني صحيح ان تبعد
يدها ايران عن حريصون على اليمن المملكه
احرص على اليمن من ايران المملكه لا تعادل
حوث المملكه تصنف الحوثي مكون يمني شريطه
ان يكون فعلا مكونا يمنيا ولا يكون ذراعا
ايرانيا فهل ستنجح ايران في هذا الجانب
لابد ان نتفائل ولابد ان نراهن ولعلها
يعني اليوم وهي تكتسب هذا الصدى الايجابي
اليوم ايران تحصل على صوره جميله اليوم
صوره ايران مبتسمه الصوره دائما يعني
هناك محاولات على الاقل هناك محاولات
وهناك سنتان من المفاوضات للوصول الى هكذا
نقطه ربما تبنى عليها امور اخرى تحدثت عن
التفاؤل وتحدثت كذلك استاذه جاسر عن
المراهنه معادله صعبه سنتحدث فيها بعض
قليل بعض نستكمل كذلك جزئيات اخرى من هذا
النقاش ولكن بعد فاصل قصير نستكمل من بعده
هذا الملف ابقوا معنا
[موسيقى]